so it's interesting with photography the
extent to which some of the great
photographers particularly the great
women photographers of the Victorian era
began just with taking the sort of
photographs that someone would take of
family members and friends and so forth
and it's through that becoming
interested in more ambitious photography
and that's the case with Beals so it's
interesting to look through her
photographs and to see the kinds of
exchanges the intimate exchanges that
photography enabled taking photographs
of loved ones or friends posing
performing for one another and these
kinds of exchanges within the homes of
that era were a very important part of
social life what was unusual about Beals
is she then took the next step and she
became a photojournalist which is not
something that very many people did much
less very many women did and and that's
rather extraordinary but one sees even
in her later work there's always an
interest in the quotidian in the
everyday in what she can see in a
gesture or an expression much of which
undoubtedly goes back to those early
years of handling photography the way
that many people did in middle-class
homes so Beals had extraordinary range
as a photographer if you go through her
photographs and the archives you
discover that she took many photographs
of animals she took photographs of
people doing amateur theatrical
performances she took street photography
she took death no graphic photographs at
the 1904 st. Louis World's Fair she did
architectural photography that range is
quite unusual a number of photographers
including some great female
photographers of the 19th century were
much more limited in their range to take
one example Julia Margaret Cameron by
most accounts the greatest Victorian
photographer stuck to a very limited
range of photographs and she just went
very deep in each of those
genres whereas Beals had a much wider
scope and looked into many different
things to photograph many of which we
can relate to now in our moment in which
cat pictures abound on the Internet it's
wonderful to go through some of the
photographs in this lesson sure and see
her remarkable capacity to take
photographs of her feline friends it's
inspiring the extent to which one sees
in the photography of Beals her
self-consciousness I mean there's many
photographs in the archive that are of
her and whether they were taken by
someone else or whether she set up the
apparatus and just had someone open and
closed the shutter we don't always know
but she clearly took herself and her
performance in the world very seriously
one of my great interests in the history
of photography is in its materiality and
in particular its openness to accident
this was understood by practitioners of
photography from very early on that here
was am a way of making pictures in which
chance played a role that was different
than the role it played in drawing or
painting or other more traditional media
so whenever I'm looking at photographs
I'm also thinking about how the
practitioner in question handled chance
and these issues of materiality
there are signs in the archive that
Beals was actually very sensitive to
these issues there's a rather marvelous
picture that she took of a sitter named
Leo Whitcomb Davis who is sitting with
ceramics tools in front of her on a
table before a window through which
light streams and she's glazing a piece
of pottery and what I love about this
photograph is the self reflexivity of it
insofar as pottery and photography have
some very significant commonalities
first of all you have the play of the
glazing of the pod and the glazing of
the window
through which the light streams which is
calling up the operation of photography
in the way that light streams into the
camera but also in both photography and
pottery you apply this film to this
object you stick it in the dark and then
out comes something that was to a
certain extent unpredictable and every
Potter has experienced that and every
photographer has experienced that and I
think in this beautiful quite exquisite
photograph she brings this dialogue to
the fore one of the aspects of Beals
photography that I think is very
important to register is her social
conscience and there's one photograph in
particular and the collection of the
Schlesinger library that really brings
that home for me it's a photograph of a
dim alleyway in Washington DC with
dilapidated homes on both sides but as
you look down this stretch of very
unappealing roadway you see at the end
of it rising up the Dome of the US
Capitol all sparkling and white and it's
that contrast between the lived reality
the material conditions of some of the
more dilapidated quarters of Washington
DC on the one hand and then this symbol
of national might on the other that I
think clearly speaks to a social
conscience about the state of affairs in
the world in which she was living
you